new warnings from the cdc tonight as
covid cases jump
nationwide the agency now saying
vaccinated americans can transmit
the delta variant just as easily as
those who are unvaccinated
it also adds that this variant is more
contagious than the common cold
data also shows that the shots work 97
percent of those hospitalized with the
virus are not
vaccinated thanks for joining us here at
11 o'clock i'm denise valdez and i'm
brian loftis so with that new
information showing that really
anyone can get covet and infect others
with it
what more can be done to protect
yourself marco mana joining us now live
with some easy ways to boost your
immunity orco
denise and brian we've been hearing the
same messages from health officials for
a while now
get vaccinated and aware of mass but
there are other things you can do
such as exercise and take supplements to
help protect yourself
against covid i'm doing what i can
to be proactive instead of reactive i
don't want to get sick
patrick cassell previously had the
coronavirus and lost his mother to the
disease last year that's why he's taking
simple steps to keep covid at bay as
transmission of the delta variant rises
even among
vaccinated people he's going to the gym
i'm walking
then i'm doing on either the bike or the
elliptical i swim
and he's taking lots of vitamins and
supplements
vitamin c on a daily basis i do zinc i
do i do a
sublingual as well so i'm taking vitamin
e the vitamin d's
they're really i'm making sure
everything i can do to prevent getting
sick is there
nurse practitioner alexandria lightning
agrees that's a good idea
certain things like the zinc are
actually
a viral antiviral so they can actually
cut
short viral replication and help
decrease viral load of covid
she adds that everyday actions can also
help boost our immunity
losing weight watching what we eat
decreasing the sugars and things in our
diet
lightning says it's crucial to combine
all these tools together but are they
actually effective with the delta
variant in the mix
100 percent they're still very helpful
cassal says he's definitely noticing a
difference
it works i haven't felt this good in a
long time
experts also say taking a melatonin
supplement right before bed
can help regulate your immune system
which in turn can help prevent
covet 19. reporting live in las vegas
tonight orco mana 8 news now